привести нам потрібно повинні дві
вантажівки Дафи і те що стосується
зв'язку
фонду Петра Порошенка дві автівки багато
нижчеків запасні колеса для машин того
що потрібно Ми багато місяців маємо
абсолютно дружні відносини з
23-м стрілецьким батальйоном ті його
командиром паном Олександром велика
кількість наших бойових побратимів із
солідарності справи громад з братів
озброєнь мають високу честь прибувати в
23 батальйоні вже милим рік не батальйон
рік і два місяці
тому трошки втомилися Ну нічого
І от Сьогодні 23 батальйону ми передаємо
два Дафа ми передаємо стерлінки
передаємо нічні мавіки ви передаємо
десяток радіостанцій зв'язок завжди у
нас це саме головне управління боєм таку
допомогу у нашому батальйону сьогодні
надали і це нам допоможе працює
потрібно щось дзвонять і ви і ми до
возимо цю допомогу нашим героїчним
блогерам Я дуже вдячний
за таку надану нам допомогу це дуже
вчасно до речі так що приймайте
Треба зібратися
набратися сил і нанести остаточний
удар для того щоб перемогти